(upbeat music)
(audience claps and cheers)
- What the what?
- Yay! Aww guys, yay. (claps)
- You two look incredible!
- Thank you.
- Wow.
- This feels so great here.
- You walked out
and I felt inferior.
(Catherine laughs)
- No.
- And the moment that I saw you.
You look fantastic.
I am so excited that you both are here.
I'm such a fan of both of you.
- Oh, I'm a fan of yours.
- Same, yeah.
- We've gotten to talk
before. You are new here.
I have to ask though.
Everybody, we're such huge
fans of "Schitt's Creek."
- Aww, thanks.
- So, where did
Moira's voice come from?
Like how did you decide?
- Actually, I knew, I think
originally it was written
sort of a little more smart ass,
and kind of calling Eugene's
character on getting
us in the situation
and giving him a hard time.
- Yeah.
- And very funny.
But I just thought I'd
seen that done so well
by other people that I was getting...
And so I wanted to be more feminine.
- Well, it's been done
by you in "Beetlejuice,"
by the way. (laughs)
- Oh, yeah, that's true.
- The mother was
kind of a smart ass.
I love that.
- Yes, but when I argue
I feel like I get very harsh and stuff,
and I just wanted
- You get awesome.
- to be feminine.
But I know a woman who is so feminine,
and I thought that what a great way to go.
Just be soft and keep
the mouth moving softly.
(all laugh)
Yeah. Just. (laughs)
(audience claps and cheers)
- It's surreal. It's surreal.
- So incredible.
I've been very excited about this moment.
Anyway, do you ever take
inspiration from like real people
that you know for characters?
- You know, sometimes things are just
sort of like obvious and make sense.
- Yeah.
- And there was one time
I was doing a movie and yeah, no,
someone did something quite awful,
and their walk just made sense for this
character that I played in "The Help."
And so-
- Oh my God,
what a great film!
Y'all have been in so many great films.
- So it was, yeah, no, it was a walk.
- Yeah.
- And it was,
- Wow.
- And everyone who knew
this person knew that it was her.
Oh, I love the hidden tokens.
- That's great.
- Wow, that's amazing.
- Yes.
- Well, speaking of walking, you got a lot
of your like physical
comedy from your dad, right?
- I did, yeah.
- It was some kind of walk, right?
- Yeah, I did a walk in
the end of "Best in Show"
where I've hurt my knee. (laughs)
And the day before we, you
know, it was improvised movie,
but it was all in the script.
Everything, all the
outline except dialogue.
And the night before Chris said,
"What are we gonna do when?"
Chris Guest said, "What are
you gonna do when you fall?"
I said, "There's this walk my
dad would do. Could I try?"
He's, "Let me see it."
And he just said, "Oh, yes."
(all laugh)
Yeah, so we did.
My dad would walk ahead
of us going into church
or going into a mall or something.
We'd all laugh and
everyone of the seven kids
in our family does the walk.
But I got to do it in a movie. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, you got to be the first.
That's a lot of siblings.
- [Catherine] Yeah, six. Six be a...
Yeah.
- That's where
the humor comes in.
- Catherine O'Hara.
- You have to, you have to laugh.
- We do.
My mom and dad laughed every day.
It was so great and sexy.
- Yeah.
Oh, I agree. I agree.
- Well, speaking of family,
Bryce shared this old photo,
so we're gonna put that.
Look, okay.
Where are you there?
- [Bryce] You know, I don't even like
really know necessarily.
- But you're winking at us. (laughs)
- Oh, am I?
Oh no, I'm, you know what it is.
I'm like, I'm very sensitive to sun so.
- Me too.
- So, yes.
So it's very likely that I
just couldn't see anything.
(all laugh)
- Yeah, but my family,
we always go on road trips.
That's always the thing that I would do.
Kind of like growing up.
- Yeah.
- And it would always be these road trips.
And no one enjoyed them
except for my mother.
- (laughs) Forced family fun.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it was like the second
like the car door was shut,
we knew that like, there was no escaping
for at least six and a half hours.
And so it was just like,
did you bring the bananas with you?
Like, it was like very intense.
But it was, you know, like there were,
there were definitely a
lot of great memories.
And then there were a few weird ones.
One time my parents were
driving from LA to Yosemite
and they left my 11-year-old brother
in a Krispy Kreme in Los Angeles.
(audience laughs)
And it took them four
hours to figure it out.
- Oh!
- And they arrived
in Yosemite.
- Four hours!
- Four hours.
- That's bad.
- What kind of therapy has
this one been through? (laughs)
- I know, I know. Well actually-
- I feel really good as a mother now.
(all laugh)
- It's very "Home Alone,"
actually. (laughs)
- Totally "Home Alone."
- Leaving the kid.
- No, that was reasonable.
That was...
(all laugh)
No four hours?
- Four hours.
- He was in a Krispy Kreme.
It's a nice place to hang.
- There are worse places.
- But then it became eight hours,
because my parents needed
to drive back to get him.
- Oh.
- And my mom cried the entire
time, and they show up,
and my, you know, this is
a little stereotypical,
so I apologize if I offend anyone.
He was surrounded by cops
and they were all eating donuts together.
He was fine.
(all laugh)
- It's what it is.
- He was fine.
- I mean, we all eat
donuts, not just cops.
They're good.
- Yes, yes.
- They're good.
- Especially when you get
there and they're warm.
I mean, so I've heard.
(all laugh)
(audience cheers and claps)
So their new movie is called "Argylle."
It's in theaters and IMAX
nationwide starting tomorrow.
So before we get to "Argylle,"
'cause we, I don't even know how we're
gonna explain it without spoiling it,
but before we get to that,
I heard that there is a
"Beetlejuice 2," possibly.
- Yeah, there is.
(Kelly gasps)
- Oh my God.
(audience cheers and claps)
- Well, I heard that you actually met your
husband on the set of "Beetlejuice."
- (laughs) I did.
Yeah, he was a production designer,
designed all those wild sets.
- Yeah.
- And they actually did
redid the whole house
on the same hill in
Vermont for this second-
- For the second one?
- Yeah, for the
second "Beetlejuice."
But he, yeah, he was
talking to me every day.
It was like high school.
He was just talking to me every day,
like by our lockers.
And then he never asked me out.
And then he went on to
prep the stuff in Vermont,
and I'm grousing to Tim Burton about how
the production designer
never asked me out.
And he said, "Let me see what I can do."
And I got there first
day of shooting there.
Bo is off to the side.
Bo Welch is his name.
He comes and he goes,
"Um, would like to go,
the art department's going to a swap meet.
You want to come with us?"
(all laugh)
- Wow.
- It looked like he'd been forced.
- Really reeling you in. Yeah. (laughs)
- I guess, but Tim was right.
- Yeah.
- Made it happen.
- I love that you got set up.
This is actually for some
reason tracks for me,
but like, as a gift for a wedding gift.
He gave you a tour of the Vatican?
- Tim did? Yeah.
A private, no private.
- Okay, but I'm just like,
that is the most random wedding
gift I've ever heard of.
- It's amazing.
- How is it possible?
- Somebody had given it to him.
I don't know, it's a
very inside kind of deal.
(audience laughs)
- What was the-
- Okay, a priest took us around.
He got yelled at, at one point.
I wish I spoke Italian,
but he was definitely
getting yelled at by another
priest because we were
in the pope's closet.
Like looking at garments.
It was crazy.
We were in the elevator
- What?
- that he takes down to St.
Peter's Basilica to do mass.
We were in this lovely
little, like a tiny museum
where all the gifts to the
Vatican from every country,
from every country leader in the world.
Gifts that had been sent to the Vatican
since the beginning of the Vatican.
And this priest is letting us open cases
and pretending to put a
crown inside Bo's backpack
taking pictures.
I wish I had those pictures with me.
Just crazy.
- You don't have these pictures?
- Somewhere I do, yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh man. That's amazing.
- Yeah, but what a, yeah,
it was beautiful gift.
Very generous.
- It's such a random gift.
A very memorable, I'll give him that.
- You were rummaging
around the pope's closet?
- Yes.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] As one does.
- [Bryce] That's like when you're like
- I hate to say this out loud. Sorry.
- going to like real estate or something
and you're like, "Oh,
I'm just gonna go like,
walk to these open houses,
and then you're just
gonna peek around a little bit."
- I was like, "No, no, yes."
(all laugh)
- I will take it. I will.
Have you, what were
your wedding gifts like?
Any comparison there?
- Well, I made, I don't
wanna say I made a mistake,
I don't regret it, but
I was one of the first
or the first person of my
group to kind of get married.
My husband was 24, I was 25.
- Yeah.
- And at the time we were like, you know,
vegan, raw foodists, and
very much so you vote
with your dollar and all that.
And so it was a wedding
of like in lieu of gifts.
Right.
In lieu of gifts.
Might you donate to or consider something.
- That's beautiful.
- It was great, except for now,
like I still don't have
a proper set of dishes.
(all laugh)
Like there are so, we realized this,
we were like, there are so
many things that you just
as like a, like a young person, you don't
know to stock yourself with these things.
- Yes.
- And it's taken 20 years
for us to learn how to feed each other.
Honestly.
- Yes.
I suffer from this too.
- Yeah.
- You get paid for jobs though.
You could probably
afford your dishware now.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah. so it's like,
you know what, that actually, I'm no joke.
- Higher pay for women.
That's what I say.
(all laugh)
- No joke though.
- We need to afford dishes.
- This last year, I
finally, 'cause you know,
after the pandemic and
stuff, it was sort of like,
ha ha enough is enough.
- Yeah.
- And we finally went out and like yeah,
did the grownup thing.
- It's fun.
- Yeah. I mean, I'm in my
forties now, so it makes sense.
- I am too, but I'm mix-matched.
I've always been that way.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I don't know, it's fun.
I have to, there's no segue here.
This movie is so fun.
There is so much action.
- Yeah.
- "Argylle" is incredible.
You've never seen anything like it.
Okay, let's talk about, first of all,
how do you explain this
movie without giving it away?
What have you been doing
on your promo tour?
- It's really hard.
And let me just say to everyone right now,
we are intentionally withholding reveals,
because we want people to go on the ride.
It is so fun.
- Yeah.
- The way we are permitted
to talk about the movie.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Is, it's kind of, you know,
Matthew Vaughn makes these
incredible like spectacle
spy extravaganza films.
- Oh my gosh.
- Really fun.
- And also like music videos.
- Totally, totally.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so much of like when you
think about like spy cinema,
it's a fantasy.
I play a spy novelist.
She's created this franchise
of books called "Argylle."
Henry Cavill is Argylle.
- Yeah.
- He's perfect. It makes sense.
So, my character's trying
to finish her book.
Catherine plays my mother.
- Yes.
- And so it's, she's going, her cat
and her mom are her best friends.
And she's on this-
- The cat is so cute.
- He's so cute. He's so cute.
And she's on her way to get some support,
and on a train and encounters a real spy.
- And then everything goes awry.
- Everything goes awry.
- And then it keeps, there's
more and more twists.
I loved it.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- But it has a sense of humor too.
Sorry, it's like, I mean it's,
Matthew Vaughn's done so
many great action movies,
but this has even more humor.
- Yeah.
- And it's sort of making fun of itself.
Somebody said it's turned
action movies inside out.
- Yeah.
- I'd say right side up too.
- Yeah, it's poking at it a bit.
It's really great.
- One of the reasons why
I was so excited to work
with Matthew was to learn
how he shoots action.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause what he does
is so distinctive.
And what I learned is that
a huge part of his process
is a partnership with
someone named Brad Allen,
who very tragically, he's one of the best
action directors in the world.
And he very tragically passed away
two weeks before shooting.
And he had designed all
of the action sequences.
He passed away at the age of 48.
- Oh wow. So young.
- And um-
Very young. And the film
is dedicated to him.
And so really, you know, this is
an ode to him and his work and his team.
- Yeah.
- And these-
- It's incredible.
- They're the best performers,
athletes.
- I'm not gonna ruin it,
but the gun scene, whatever.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But the, yeah, I was like, "What?"
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And they were so was-
- It's like a dance.
- Yes, it was Sam Rockwell
- Beautiful. Yeah.
- inspired so much
- Oh my gosh.
He's so great.
- of the dance.
You know, and so things
kind of kept expanding
and expanding.
And I would say of all the things I did,
the thing that was the
hardest was definitely
the dancing for me.
- Yeah.
For sure. For sure.
- Really?
- Yes.
- Oh my God.
- It's something you take
personally, I think too.
Dancing, isn't it?
- Yes.
- It's like, oh no,
'cause I watch actors that way.
I go, "Oh, that's how you dance. Is it?"
(all laugh)
- Yeah, that's how you do it.
- And some people try to look cool,
and some people intentionally
try to look funny.
Like, you're not gonna
see how I really dance.
- Yeah.
- It's such a-
- It's vulnerable.
It's so exposed.
- Oh my God, it's freeing though.